all right this one's for all the march
madness fans that'll be watching from
home this weekend although watch parties
and celebrations will look different
one local place making sure you're not
alone christian that's right well even
if your company is cardboard here's
rocky theas
with screaming images get ready to
scream for march madness we are
celebrating here getting ready i should
say getting geared up for march madness
here at screaming images
a local company james you started this
19 years ago almost so congratulations
thank you very much this is so cool i
love it in here and we're learning
obviously we're hanging out with the
raiders their printouts we got
you know some famous ones you might
recognize here but how does this work
the life size uh we just we cut we uh we
we get pictures high resolution pictures
of whoever we're going to be cutting out
and
we kind of cut a die-cut line around it
and send it out to press
and then send it to our router in the
back and cut it out to shape that's so
cool so let's take a walk around this
cool place and understand how the
operation
works i see something being printed
right now yeah so this is a
efi 3250 it's a latex ink it's 10 foot
wide
and this this this is a called a hybrid
it prints
rigid prints like this which means it's
going on to a rigid substrate and also
prints roll to roll so you print banners
and wraps and stuff like that on it also
it's one of the one of the busiest
printers we have
so great for businesses but also since
we're talking about march madness it's
great for fans because we can't be at
the games but we can
kind of bring the fun to the living room
yeah through you guys how can we do that
we have a we have an order portal on our
website so people can call and order
them up a lot of people like to do it
for parties we have a
yes a lot of uses we put those to you
like kids ordering for birthday parties
we have uh
people ordering for office celebrations
like if they have an anniversary or
something
and you know we not just people we cut
out jet skis motorcycles
boats surfboards we we have a lot of
camp
national customers that we do uh retail
campaigns for so we ship them all over
the country so there's
there's a lot of things you can cut out
that is so cool let's come over here and
take a look at some of the cutouts
you've done i'll host
a few over i'll hold a few up we've got
this girl we've got
this guy okay we've got this lady here
so what's it looking like how are your
orders coming through for the weekend
uh pretty steady um on the orders like
this for the fan cutouts
we're doing those pretty much for
charity and we're donating 100
to some of our local charities like boys
and girls club animal shelters stuff
like that oh that's great and then
and then i i believe you guys do
something else too i see some shields
yeah this is just the standard
polycarbonate dividers that they're
doing in casinos offices
schools we're doing them at a legion
stadium t-mobile arena so
dope all right so coming up later in the
show i feel like
i got to get myself on the printer what
do you guys think yeah
good idea i'll be official all right
we'll be back later